from NBC News Nikki Haley loses to none
of these candidates in the Nevada GOP
Primary that's right Nikki Haley was
running in the primary she took it very
very seriously she did wait till wait
wait till you see the clip we're going
to play from an interview and uh she
lost To None that's right she lost to No
One quite literally like no one beat her
no no no like quote no one end quote
beat her like when people were given the
choice between Nikki Haley and someone
else anybody please not her
somebody anybody please not her One MH
and so it's been an excellent day of
memes Andrew claven said uh don't make
fun of her for losing to none of these
candidates none of these candidates ran
a great campaign and none of these
candidates is qualified to be the
president of the United States very
clever but um where's that uh here we go
let let me play this clip for you so you
can hear it for yourself what she had to
say does that situation Nevada hurt a
little bit no I mean Nevada it's such a
a scam they were supposed to have a
primary Trump rigged it so that the GOP
chairman who's been indicted would go
and create a caucus we knew months ago
that we weren't going to spend a day or
a dollar in Nevada because it wasn't
worth it and so we didn't even count
Nevada that wasn't anything we were
looking at we knew that was rigged oh I
love oh it was rigged from the start it
was rigged from the start Trump rigged
it she's an election denier I I just
love this so much because she's like
it's it's qu like we should stop saying
sour grapes and start saying Nikki
losing in Nevada because she's just like
I didn't want to win the primary anyway
like who cares it was rigged it was so
dumb want it it is actually dumb because
she took it seriously enough to register
to be on the ballot despite the fact
that the RNC is awarding based off the
caucus which is tomorrow like she is now
saying I know I'm going to lose in the
caucus and Nevada so she's getting out
ahead of the message of like well not
only did you lose to literally no one
you also lost to Trump she's saying it
never mattered which how could you like
her if you're a Nevada voter but you
know that if she she did get first place
and none of these candidates didn't
didn't make a mark she'd be saying look
that's Trump's fault I won the Primary
those delegates are mine blah blah blah
instead she you lose yeah is it zero
rigged it he rigged it yeah he rigged it
he rigged it she's banging she said it
twice I think she did um she did she
probably said more I stopped the video
26 seconds in are is it Nevada zero
delegates is that what I was reading
zero I thought they said they had zero
delegates for the primary oh okay yeah
the caucus they're they're doing a
caucus to award I think what is it what
what is that it's because they want to
remove his name from The Ballot or
something or what that's why they moved
to a caucus yeah I mean so Nevada's
weird because they tried really hard to
say like in 2021 they passed this law
saying we are actually the state that
gets to hold the first of the nation uh
caucus or first the nation primary and
they had been from what I understand a
caucus system beforehand and uh this is
all leading into the time where the
Democratic National Party spent a lot of
time saying actually we want to rework
the entire schedule we don't want Iowa
and New Hampshire to go first we don't
think it represents the vo voter base
basically saying they're not diverse
enough States and so they want to lead
with South Carolina and Nevada and go
into a different schedule and so you're
seeing this year uh Republicans having
races in some states and sometimes
they're held at the same time as
Democrats and other times they're not so
like the South Carolina primary for the
Democrats was uh February 3rd but the
South Carolina primary for the
Republicans is I think it's February 26
right at the end of the month uh so
because they're parties are operating
differently just like so the Republican
saying well even though you have now
passed a state law saying you have to
have a primary we are still having the
caucus and that's what we're awarding is
very similar to what um the Democrats
did in New Hampshire which is to say
even though it's state law there you
have to have the first and the nation
primary they they discouraged the
Democratic uh New Hampshire Democrats
from holding one and they said if you do
we won't award any delegates based on
that so you're just seeing this
bifurcation of we want to control the
order in which states vote I I just
pulled it up the the issue is that they
passed a law in 2021 to uh get rid of
the caucuses the Republicans said that's
ridiculous primaries are not secure and
they said no and they said well we're
only counting the caucus anyway yeah so
the RNC is is taking authority over the
states basically well the state can do
what they can say whatever they want but
the part's private yeah both parties are
doing this like if you look at New
Hampshire the Democrat National the
Democrat the DNC was like we're not
counting your primary votes because you
are not obeying our order and the
Republicans said to Dada we don't care
that you want to hold a primary we want
a caucus here that's what we've always
done and so it it's weird it's unusual
on the other hand I think it just shows
how much people don't trust the voter
system I mean what the Democrats are
selling right now is that if we follow
the old order we're basically following
racism they have said Andrew Biden has
uh endorsed this that we have to change
the order of the States they're really
drifting far apart I I I just I have a I
have a real question there's a real real
one I I what would possess Nikki Haley
into figuratively
standing in public and begging people to
throw spoiled rotten garbage at her I
mean like this is one of the most
humiliating things a person could
personally ask for so apparently she's
not going to be in the caucus her name's
not in the caucus she's only in the
primary and she lost to none of these
candidates I I wonder if she actually
thought she was going to win she's like
with Trump not in the ballot I get first
place and then she doesn't and she gets
beat by literally any like just not her
does it mean that they wrote his name in
that's basically no no one of the
options was none of these candidates you
could vote for none of these candes
literally and and none beat Nikki Haley
I like double too I double it was it was
double I feel like this spin I mean it
just reeks of insincerity and probably
you know focus group sessions of all of
her big corporate and Democrat donors
but they're like what is the Trump base
really like talk about you know rigged
elections so that's what we're going to
say we're going to try to like pull the
trump card and be like oh it was rigged
oh we didn't even like it's sort there's
something sort of like Trump esque about
right the way that she's approaching go
on the offense you have to attack
exactly but like it doesn't work cuz no
one actually likes you and you actually
lost well she's an election denier now
she is she should join the
club govern Joe Lombardo was one of the
first people at least I saw I'm sure
other people had said it who had said
you know I am going to partake in the
primary because that's what's happening
in our state but I'm going to vote for
none of none of these candidates because
I I don't want anyone here I'm he's been
always been a really big supporter of
trump and so I just think Nikki Haley
was hoping that there were I think she
Mis uh she underestimated the support
that Trump has on the populace level
especially among State Governors I mean
not even the governor of her own State
South Carolina which is basically the
next thing that she's leading up to
saying I hope I can win South Carolina
none of the Republicans in South
Carolina the entire ad like the entire
administration of government like all
the Republicans just endorse Trump
everybody but I don't even think the
variable here is like Nikki Haley and
what she thinks is politically wise for
her to do it's the donors who are
propping her up she's more or less uh to
quote someone a listless vessel and I
think that's right I think that she it's
not about actually analyzing like boots
on the ground voters it doesn't matter
because she's not she knows she's not
going to win deep down to her Court you
think she have she'd have enough
self-esteem to be like I don't want to
be the puppet be in front of all of this
and be humiliated like this like she's
saying stuff now that she's never going
to take be able to take back and it just
shows how unpopular she is I mean where
does she go in terms of her political
career after being wrecked over and over
again she'll run in
26 or 28 or whatever I just like I I I
just the most embarrassing thing a
person could you sort of understand her
foreign policy how okay with losing all
I I I just I'm sorry like the
humiliation the utter humiliation that
she's experiencing and you can see it in
her face like no it doesn't matter
matter we didn't even care like we
didn't even want to be in Nevada you
Trump rigged it he rigged it I didn't
hold on I care enough to register but I
don't actually care at all whoa whoa
whoa which is it did you always know you
were never going to spend any money in
Nevada or are you upset that Trump
rigged it and you actually wanted to win
and you got your name on the ballot I
think she thought she was going to get
it for sure and then instead she just
got like she was just standing right
between the the sewage pipe and right in
public in front of everybody and she's
standing there going I didn't want to
stand you in the first place you're all
dumb I didn't I didn't want to spend
money it's like dude it's not sour
grapes like to say that people have
short memories is kind of vague
generalization it's not always true some
people have great memories but a lot of
people reading the past history and
watching the patterns they don't they
forget like Joe Biden resigned from his
run for president in 19 in 1988 because
he was plagiarizing humiliation no you
should never have a guy like that in
office but people whatever reason forgot
I was never told I had to find out
through you know securist means
eventually in 2009 or something M so I
think she's going to be groomed to run
with somebody's VP in 2008 28 or 32
they're just they're going to keep her
around and now this is good all
publicity is good publicity crap it's
not it's all good all publicity is not
good publicity not with the Internet
it's a little different with internet
video it's it's different like this this
is bad for her brand it turns her into a
clown like holy crap I got to say man
you know the pr people build those thing
is bad press I'm like I kind of think
there is like you losing To None
basically makes you the least viable
candidate ever this point moving on like
who you you can't run for anything you
can't run for for class president at
this point you can't run for the P what
federal position is available to her
right now because she's not going to get
a position in the Trump Administration
that's just the way it is and you know
she's not super welcome in her home
state you'll hear interviews with South
Carolina voters who say you know she was
a great Governor I just don't see her as
president whatever else but now it seems
like the voters who have elected the
current guard of leaders in South
Carolina wouldn't support her either I
mean they have drifted more favorably
towards Trump the longer she stays in
this battle with Trump the more she
isolates herself from most Republican
voters but I think she she's more
concerned about what the defense
Contracting industry thinks of her and
what cushy gigs and retainer fees she'll
be able to get I don't think she gives a
I won't cuss but anything about the
Republican Bas or she wouldn't have
first of all stepped in she would have
stepped out a while ago and I think it's
just sort of performative uh activism I
would say to get a cushy gig at whether
it's Ron Boeing choose your corporate
you know sugar but she already had those
I mean she could have stayed she is
choosing to go back into politics
because she craves the power is my
assumption I feel like she's being
pushed like she's sitting in a driver's
seat of a self-driving car well Ken
Griffin gave her what he gave a super
pack like $5 million but then he was
interviewed and he was like yeah I don't
think she she's going to win so uh but
it's not I think why it comes off so dis
ingenuous is that they're not giving
money to her because they actually liked
her right Ronda santis was sort of the
first pick but then he obviously was the
sacrificial lamb it didn't work out then
maybe it was going to be Glenn yunan now
it's Nikki Haley so I think there's that
lack of authenticity because they don't
actually believe in her it's just the
way things have sort of happened the way
the the tables have turned the cards
have played it's like she's the last one
standing and yeah maybe she's a woman so
it makes them feel better but I don't I
don't really think there's like I said
she's a listless vessel for these
corporate donors who often times are are
majority Democrat but she's just sort of
a walking shell of their interests you
think those people care about the Maga
base the Republican base they're
probably laughing oh these dumb idiots
are going to think if we say the word
rigged let's focus group that word like
that's going to go over with them
because they're really into election
denialism but it shows you how to touch
they are I I will give her credit she
learned how to talk while opening and
closing her mouth it was funny because I
tweeted like Nikki Haley when she speaks
she doesn't move her teeth and then it
was It was kind of wild because they
were people like they got to be PR
account something defending her saying
your teeth don't move when you talk and
I was like dude your mouth opens and
closes and your teeth are going up and
down but when she talks she keeps her
jaw still and she talks through her lips
like this it's like she's yelling at her
dog you know what I mean like you know
your dog that's the adjective is that
what you're doing when you like how dare
you I will lock my teeth together you
got the garbage against her energy style
tur but in this I I noticed she looks
tur I don't know she figured out how to
speak with uh opening and closing her
mouth which she laughed nervously in the
beginning of the interview you tell
she's a mess right now what is Nikki
there you go got to drop out n sorry
nimada so these people that are funding
her campaign are they basically ready to
profit off of global organization like
Global Finance if if the US amalgam ises
into this new world order thing PE just
just try and understand it you know Ian
I think I think you're too self-centered
I think you to understand it from their
perspective if someone came to you and
said blowing up a bunch of kids would
put a million bucks in your pocket you'd
say yes right I don't think so you got
but you got I'd like to hear more about
the plan I say no but try to hear it
from her donor's perspective you know
what I mean like you blow up a bunch of
kids over there and you get money over
here okay right that's the argument okay
I'll I'll play along I'll smly Butler
this tell me more Butler this why would
anyone in their right mind like I guess
they just love blowing up why they are
would support this this is what I'm
wondering I think there are a lot of
people that are are down are ready to
profit on the transfer of power from
theeran American LED economic order to
the new global economic order and
they're like we're going to make so much
money off our Black Rock Investments off
of they already are and so if Nikki so
they're willing to put 5 million behind
Nikki because she's probably what I
would imagine passively go along with it
where Trum they all want to be the one
who has a president who's in their
pocket right I mean you want to be able
to call on the favors that's that's
really why a lot of people donate to
political campaigns to ultimately have
influence over the cidate that's exactly
what we're see going on right right now
on the hill right with this immigration
Bill like most americ people I think
immigration is the issue that we're
probably gaslit the hardest on but most
average Americans have absolutely no
demonal benefit from allowing illegal
immigration right it's a wage killer
doesn't make our CI safer but those same
people who are donating to Nikki Haley's
campaign they love the open border they
love the cheap labor right they don't
believe in sovereignty I also believe
there's an element of ideological
compromise too but I think for so long
we've been accustomed to politics where
there's really no meaningful difference
between Republican and Democrat right
whether it's the unip party critique or
however you want to perceive it it but I
I really think that's why Trump was so
transformational because he changed that
and made the Republican Party really a
party of the working class and even you
see punch bows sort of analysis of what
happened on the hill today specifically
on that border bill they said it was the
death of the old Republican party right
it was so long you know it used to be
McConnell could get his you know watered
down conservative border bills passed
because there wasn't meaningful push
back and I think the Nicki Haley of the
world the Ronda santis is of the world
it's sort of that Deja Vu to that like
pre6 era politics where all of the
Republican politics it was politicians
it was like let's just choose do we want
to bomb Iraq or Syria and how many kids
do we want to kill it was basically just
like picking the same style of just
basically neoconservatism and I think
that's why she's not going over well but
that dying guard of donor they're not
ready to give up yet right they don't
they don't roll over without a fight and
I would not want Nikki Haley to be my
fighter even if she's wearing heels as
I'm sure she'd be uh more than certain
to point out her ammo though I don't
know what that means but that's what she
said he honestly I have to say as a
someone from La very into fashion like
her heels aren't even cute like I don't
if I were going down the heel fighting
they're ugly thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm. and become a member over at
timcast.net